I want you guys to know, I hope you're rolling on this. You ready? Here we go. I want you guys to know that this morning, this is the most serious cold to open. Yes. I've been in a rough place and this really, I feel like I've shared a lot in the last year of being in a rough place, but I have been, a lot going on. And this saved me this morning after a few days. I love that.
我想让你们知道，我希望你们能挺住。准备好了吗？我们要开始了。我想让你们知道，今天早上，这是最严肃的开场。是的。我一直处于一个艰难的境地，我觉得在过去的一年里，我分享了很多关于身处困境的事情，但我确实经历了很多。这几天之后，今天早上是这件事拯救了我。我喜欢这样。
It really saved me knowing. You might not have made it to lunchtime. No, I wouldn't have made it. I wasn't going to take my own life, but I was in a pretty bad place. And knowing that I was coming here and then getting on and seeing you guys, this has just made my day.
知道这一点真的拯救了我。你可能都没撑到午饭时间。不，我撑不到。我不是要自杀，但我当时确实处于一个非常糟糕的境地。知道我要来这里，然后上线见到你们，这让我的这一天变得很美好。
That's it. No joke. Isn't that nice? And is that why you took a little shower, a little self-care, combed your hair, put on a nice top? I wanted to look nice for you guys. You know, I wanted to show up here and be respectful of the process.
就是这样。不开玩笑。这不是很棒吗？这就是你洗了个澡、做了点自我护理、梳了头、穿了件漂亮上衣的原因吗？我想在你们面前看起来体面一点。你知道，我想来到这里，并对这个过程表示尊重。
The thing I can count on is you two ding-dongs. Yeah. And then the other three ding-dongs who we work with as well, Rob and Bennett and Michael. I know it's a late Thanksgiving. It's been a minute, but I want to say thank you. And I'm very grateful for you guys. We love you.
我能指望的就是你们两个笨蛋。是的。还有我们一起工作的另外三个笨蛋，罗伯、贝内特和迈克尔。我知道感恩节已经过去很久了。有一阵子了，但我还是想说谢谢。我非常感激你们。我们爱你。
And we thank you. And you make our day, too. Anytime you want. And so let's I'm very grateful for you guys. We love you and we thank you and you make our day too. Anytime you want. And so let's try to make other people's days and let's get into a nice fresh episode of Smartless. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. I was speaking of medical conditions. I know, I can't even. I can't even.
我们也谢谢你。你也让我们的这一天变得很美好。随时都可以。所以让我们……我非常感激你们。我们爱你，我们也谢谢你，你也让我们的这一天变得很美好。随时都可以。所以让我们试着让别人的这一天也变得美好，让我们进入《Smartless》新鲜的一集。Smart。Less。Smart。Less。说到医疗状况。我知道，我简直……我简直……
You don't wanna talk about it? We can talk, I'm an open book, I'll talk about anything. Shaunie wakes up in the middle of the night with his heart thingy for everybody other than Tracy, the reminder is he's got an Afib situation, right? Which necessitates the paddles at the emergency room every once in a while. It's just insane.
你不想谈这个吗？我们可以谈，我是个透明人，什么都能谈。肖尼在半夜醒来，心脏出了点小毛病，对于特雷西以外的每个人，提醒一下，他有房颤的情况，对吧？这需要偶尔在急诊室用电击除颤。这简直太疯狂了。
It's like if you had a car that would constantly just like have trouble getting started, you would eventually replace the battery. So you're replacing me on SmartList? Well, nor just your heart. No, we thought about it for one second. We never even... Can we get you on a list for a fresh pump?
就像如果你的车总是很难启动，你最终会更换电池。所以你要在《SmartList》上替换我？嗯，不是，只是你的心脏。不，我们考虑过一秒钟。我们甚至从来没有……我们能把你列入更换新泵的名单吗？
We didn't do a deep dive. So he wakes up in the middle of the night and his heart's not working correctly or so he thinks. And so he doesn't want to wake up Scotty. So he calls away Mo for himself and gets himself to the ER. And Scotty wakes up later with a phone call from Sean from the ER saying, hey buddy, I'm here, just wanna give you a heads up.
我们没有深入研究。所以他在半夜醒来，心脏工作不正常，或者他自己这么认为。他不想吵醒斯科蒂。所以他自己叫了救护车，去了急诊室。斯科蒂后来醒来，接到了肖恩从急诊室打来的电话，说，嘿伙计，我在这儿，只是想告诉你一声。
So I guess it's kind of nice that he doesn't wanna trouble Scotty and worry him and just calls him from. J.B., not once, twice. Yeah, on the same night. I got cardioverted twice, so I went under and then Jimmy Kimmel calls me paddles, right, because of this. So paddles got it twice that night, where my cardio,
所以我猜他不想麻烦斯科蒂，不想让他担心，只是从那里给他打电话，这还挺好的。J.B.，不是一次，是两次。是的，在同一个晚上。我被电击除颤了两次，所以我失去了知觉，然后吉米·坎摩尔叫我“电击板”，对吧，因为这个。所以“电击板”那天晚上被电了两次，我的心脏……
and yeah, it was pretty scary. And yet you still made it out to dinner the following night. You weren't in a great place that night. No, I was a little foggy, I was a little foggy. Oh yeah, of course you were. More so than usual. You've been electrocuted twice. Your body had been, you know, that's a lot.
是的，那真的很可怕。但你第二天晚上还是出来吃晚饭了。那天晚上你的状态不太好。不，我有点头晕，我有点头晕。哦，是的，当然了。比平时更晕。你被电击了两次。你的身体，你知道，那可是很大的冲击。
So what, are we all right? By the way, the nurse told me, wow, before I did it, she goes, you know, I had a big tough cop come in here once, and he said, I don't want to be put under when you do the paddles, you know, clear, go, and the cop is like, he's like, I don't want it, I don't want to be put under. She's like, sir, no, everybody is put under. She's like, nope, nope, I don't want it. And she goes want to be put on her. She's like, sir, no, everybody is put on her. He's like, nope, nope, I don't want it.
所以，我们还好吗？顺便说一句，护士告诉我，哇，在我做之前，她说，你知道，我曾经遇到过一个强壮的警察，他说，我不想在你们用电击板的时候被麻醉，你知道，清理，开始，那个警察就像是，他说我不想要，我不想被麻醉。她说，先生，不，每个人都要被麻醉。她说，不，不，我不想要。然后她说想被麻醉。她说，先生，不，每个人都要被麻醉。他说，不，不，我不想要。
And she goes, I've never heard somebody scream so loud in my entire life. The guy got with Claire Gronk and he was like, ah! Why, because it hurts when it's an electrical shock, right? Well, your whole body goes, it's like being tased. Right, how do you know where it's like being tased? Sean tased. That's your new name, it's not paddle, Sean Taze.
她说，我这辈子从来没听过有人叫得那么大声。那家伙被电击时，他就像是，啊！为什么，因为电击的时候很痛，对吧？嗯，你的整个身体都会……就像被电击枪击中一样。对，你怎么知道被电击枪击中是什么感觉？肖恩被电了。那是你的新名字，不是电击板，是肖恩·电击。
Sean Taze. All right, that's enough. Yeah, I mean, you got, weren't you tased once at an Indigo Girls concert or something? What's the story on that? You had parked your Subaru with all the stickers coexist and all that stuff. You had parked, you were at... We used to say in stickers coexist and all that stuff. You were at Part, you were at... We used to say in college for the Indigo Girls. You were in Bandora again.
肖恩·电击。好了，够了。是的，我的意思是，你，你不是在Indigo Girls的演唱会上被电击枪击中过吗？那是什么故事？你停好了你的斯巴鲁，上面贴满了“共存”之类的贴纸。你停了，你在……我们过去常说在大学里看Indigo Girls。你又在班多拉了。
Okay, keep going, sorry. No, I said it's college and we'd say if you take the N and the O out of Indigo Girls, it says I did girls. Yeah. Thanks everybody. What a college. Now was this, this was at Harvard?
好吧，继续，抱歉。不，我说这是大学，我们常说如果你把Indigo Girls里的N和O去掉，就是“我做了女孩”。是的。谢谢大家。多么好的大学。这是在哈佛吗？
What a college. Hey, Sean, just to close the loop, are you on the backside of figuring out this heart thing? Yeah, I'm going today after this. I just wanna say this, all jokes aside, I and we, I speak for Jason, love you very, very much. Likewise. And the idea of you not being fully well
多么好的大学。嘿，肖恩，为了结束这个话题，你快要搞清楚这个心脏问题了吗？是的，我今天晚些时候要去。我只想说，撇开玩笑不谈，我，还有我们，我代表杰森，非常非常爱你。同样。想到你没有完全康复
is very distressing to me, to be honest. Well, thanks. And I want to make sure that you're okay. So are we doing, is there anything else? Yes, today I'm going to like a super specialist. But what does that mean? You're going up into the thigh again. Like, are we knocking you out again?
老实说，这让我非常不安。嗯，谢谢。我想确保你没事。所以我们还要做别的吗？是的，今天我要去看一位超级专家。但那是什么意思？你又要去大腿那里了吗？我们要再次把你麻醉吗？
Like, is this major surgery? It's not surgery, it's just, it's like a two hour procedure. So it's not a general, it's just that the... Or an hour. It's not even two hours, it's an hour. You getting the twilight? Propofol. Propofol, yeah.
这是大手术吗？不是手术，只是，就像一个两小时的疗程。所以不是全身麻醉，只是……或者一小时。甚至不到两小时，是一小时。你要进入那种朦胧状态吗？异丙酚。异丙酚，是的。
Oh, the greatest of all. This is what's driving all of this. You're so addicted to anesthesia. It's pretty beautiful. I know, what is, you know what happens to Mr. Jackson, right? Well, I'm not taking it to sleep. Well, you know, slippery slope. JB, you had it, right, when you got your thing?
哦，最棒的东西。这就是导致这一切的原因。你对麻醉上瘾了。这很美妙。我知道，你知道杰克逊先生发生了什么，对吧？嗯，我不是为了睡觉才用它的。嗯，你知道，滑坡谬误。JB，你做那个的时候用过，对吧？
What did I have? When we had our things, when we all had our things looked at. What happened? When they went up our butts. Oh, no, you mean the body scan? Who looked at what? A body scan?
我用了什么？当我们做我们的检查时，当我们都去检查我们的东西时。发生了什么？当他们进入我们的屁股时。哦，不，你是说全身扫描？谁看了什么？全身扫描？
No, you're talking about a colonoscopy, right? Yeah, remember? Yeah, that's just a twilight. Is that propofol? That's propofol. Now, like the cop cop I requested no anesthesia Come on keep the respectable guest Okay, let's well, let's hear it here's the go to the intro JB. This is great
不，你在说结肠镜检查，对吧？是的，记得吗？是的，那只是朦胧状态。那是异丙酚吗？那是异丙酚。现在，像那个警察一样，我要求不麻醉。得了吧，保持嘉宾的体面。好吧，让我们听听，这是介绍，JB。这太棒了。
Yeah, hey guys fresh off the pages of Wikipedia comes his very special He always talks about his special intro that he does and it turns out he looked at it, again it goes back to that thing that I hate which is people go like I did some research and I'm like oh do you have the internet? I do too. That's my wife's line. I've never, I never say I've done research on anything. I know you don't. Man, today we have simply put one of our finest filmmakers living in the world, okay? His films have received 28 Academy Award nominations, taken home nine of them and grossed nearly $2 billion.
是的，嘿伙计们，新鲜出炉的维基百科页面上写着他非常特别的……他总是谈论他做的那个特别的介绍，结果他看了看，这又回到了我讨厌的那件事，就是人们说“我做了一些研究”，我就想，哦，你有互联网吗？我也有。那是我妻子的台词。我从来没有，我从来没说过我对任何事情做过研究。我知道你没有。伙计，今天我们请到的是世界上最优秀的电影制作人之一，好吗？他的电影获得了28项奥斯卡提名，拿走了9座奖杯，票房收入近20亿美元。
His films have captured the small and the nuanced human condition as well as the enormous scope and scale of sci-fi's most complicated stories. Guys, he's our perfect guest. For Will, he's a Canadian, for me, he's a beast of a director, and Sean, he's a titan in the sci-fi world right now.
他的电影捕捉到了细微而微妙的人类状况，以及科幻小说中最复杂故事的巨大范围和规模。伙计们，他是我们完美的嘉宾。对威尔来说，他是加拿大人，对我来说，他是导演界的野兽，对肖恩来说，他是目前科幻世界的泰坦。
Ladies and gentlemen, here he comes, Denis Villeneuve. No way! You're kidding me. Oh my God, no way! I feel bad to interrupt your conversation. I apologize for the length of it. I was learning a lot of dramatic things. Oh, boy.
女士们，先生们，他来了，丹尼斯·维伦纽瓦。不会吧！你在开玩笑吧。天哪，不会吧！我很抱歉打断你们的谈话。我为谈话的时间之长道歉。我刚才学到了很多戏剧性的事情。哦，天哪。
Put out the plastic, please. You speak French? A little bit,. It's incredible that you're here today, Denis. You speak French? A little bit, but it's incredible. I just wrote you an email, like a dorky email, like three or four months ago. I don't know if you got it. You did? Yes. Hold on. Do you know him? No. It's just a fan email.
请把塑料制品拿出来。你会说法语吗？一点点。你能来这里真是太不可思议了，丹尼斯。你会说法语吗？一点点，但这太不可思议了。我几个月前刚给你写了一封邮件，像一封傻乎乎的邮件。我不知道你有没有收到。你收到了？是的。等等。你认识他吗？不。这只是一封粉丝邮件。
Yeah, I just wrote you an email, just like, oh my God. He got it, but no comment. That's right. What was it, was it notes? Was it notes on a locked picture? It was notes on Arrival. You did? I'm not sure I got that email.
是的，我只是给你写了一封邮件，就像，哦天哪。他收到了，但没有评论。没错。那是什么，是笔记吗？是关于锁定画面的笔记吗？那是关于《降临》的笔记。你做了吗？我不确定我收到了那封邮件。
I'm sorry. But you know, Arri rival I've seen, I don't know how many times, I just think it's one of the best movies ever, ever. I mean, it's just incredible. Thank you, Sean. Yeah, I- So, so much good work, my goodness.
抱歉。但你知道，《降临》我看过，不知道多少次了，我只是觉得它是史上最好的电影之一。我的意思是，这简直太不可思议了。谢谢，肖恩。是的，我……这么多优秀的作品，天哪。
Thank you. That's it. That's it, yeah, that's the interview. Thank you for joining us, bye now. All right, I go back in the dark. No, no, no. All right, so- Yeah, but it was pretty dramatic because I don't know you gentlemen
谢谢。就是这样。就是这样，是的，采访结束了。谢谢你的加入，再见。好吧，我回到黑暗中去了。不，不，不。好吧，所以……是的，但这非常戏剧性，因为我不认识你们几位。
and it was a very intense conversation you were having about your common friend that is having a heart attack. Right, but you know. I feel that. It actually sounds more intense than it is. Like, AFib, AFib doesn't cause a heart attack. Untreated, it can cause a stroke,
你们刚才在谈论你们共同的朋友心脏病发作，那是一场非常激烈的谈话。对，但你知道。我感觉到了。这听起来实际上比实际情况更激烈。比如，房颤，房颤不会导致心脏病发作。如果不治疗，它会导致中风，
but AFib itself is not that serious, I'm told. We are not a medical podcast. We are not giving any. I want a second opinion on all of this. It's just too common, these trips to the fricking emergency. Anyway, well, you know, we're all of that age. Denny, you're near us, right? We're all in our mid-50s, or close to it.
但我被告知房颤本身并不那么严重。我们不是医疗播客。我们不提供任何建议。我想对所有这些听取第二意见。这些去该死的急诊室的次数太频繁了。总之，嗯，你知道，我们都到了那个年纪。丹尼，你和我们差不多，对吧？我们都五十多岁了，或者接近这个年纪。
All this shit starts to wobble a little bit. The nuts on the wheels start to get a little loose, right? And we all start like, take it. We are at that peak and now we're starting slowly. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Stuff starts to ache. Let's think that we're maybe plateauing. Before we get to the downhill, Denny,
所有这些东西都开始有点摇晃了。轮子上的螺母开始有点松了，对吧？我们都开始……我们正处于那个巅峰，现在我们开始慢慢地……是的，是的，是的。东西开始疼痛了。让我们认为我们可能正在进入平稳期。在我们下坡之前，丹尼，
let's think that we're just enjoy a little plateau. We're on that plateau, yes, yes. Keep talking about this part. But we talk about it, we end up talking about a lot of this stuff, because Jason says, because it's happening, and also we're friends, and it's, I don't know about you guys, it does seem like,
让我们认为我们只是享受一点平稳期。我们正处于那个平稳期，是的，是的。继续谈论这个部分。但我们谈论它，我们最终谈论了很多这些事情，因为杰森说，因为这正在发生，而且我们是朋友，而且，我不知道你们怎么看，这看起来确实像是，
I said to Sean the other day, life is in session right now. It does feel like in the world, life is in session. Yeah, for sure. And you have to, I've had a certain amount of, not to get lately of surrender to it and just like, I can't fight it, I have to kind of go with the flow a little bit these days and I'm concerned about things
我前几天对肖恩说，生活现在正在进行中。在世界上，生活确实感觉正在进行中。是的，当然。你必须，我最近有一种，不是说要放弃，而是对它的一种顺从，就像，我无法抗拒，我必须在这些日子里随波逐流，我担心一些事情，
with health and with family and friends. Yeah, I literally listed all the things Will's going through last night. He's like, oh yeah, wow. But everybody is. Nothing's happening to me, life is just happening. And so anyway, so Denny, you're catching us in a moment where this is about as philosophical as we get.
关于健康，关于家人和朋友。是的，我昨晚列出了威尔正在经历的所有事情。他说，哦，是的，哇。但每个人都是这样。没有什么事情发生在我身上，生活只是在发生。所以，总之，丹尼，你赶上了我们在这个时刻，这大概就是我们能达到的最哲学的高度了。
Yeah, yeah, that's it. But the thing is that it's good that Sean is actually taking care of it and making tests as difficult as we get. The bad thing is when you have a surprise that comes out of nowhere. I lost a friend of mine that was like 58, Jean-Marc Vallee, the director of Dyer's Buyers Club. Biggest surprise, he was a healthy guy. And he just fell on the floor, bang. And it's things that's good that you,
是的，是的，就是这样。但问题是，肖恩实际上正在处理它并进行测试，这是好事。糟糕的是当你遇到一个突如其来的惊喜时。我失去了一位朋友，他才58岁，让-马克·瓦雷，《达拉斯买家俱乐部》的导演。最大的惊喜，他是个健康的人。他只是倒在地板上，砰。这些事情，很高兴你，
at least you know you are taking care of it. There's someone say, so it's gonna be good. Yeah, you have, and that gives you perspective, right? When you have that sort of, when you get that contrast, and when you see that happen, and these guys know I lost my friend, my dear friend Jeremy last year, quite suddenly as well. And that sort of, when you get that contrast, when you see that happen, and these guys know I lost my friend, my dear friend Jeremy last year, quite suddenly as well, he wasn't even,
至少你知道你在处理它。有人说，所以这会是好的。是的，你有，这给了你视角，对吧？当你有了那种，当你得到那种对比，当你看到那种事情发生时，这些家伙知道我去年失去了我的朋友，我亲爱的朋友杰里米，也非常突然。那种，当你得到那种对比，当你看到那种事情发生时，这些家伙知道我去年失去了我的朋友，我亲爱的朋友杰里米，也非常突然，他甚至没有，
I guess he was, had just turned 53 at the time. And it was very sudden. And it really does, it really puts everything in perspective a little bit, you know? For me it did, I don't know about you with losing your friend, but the perspective was. Absolutely, absolutely, it was a little bit, you know, for me it did I don't know about you with losing your friend, but it the perspective Absolutely, absolutely. It's a big shock. Yeah, the things that the doctor said is what is shocking and what we don't accept is that People actually have days of peremption. I mean there's a
我想他当时刚满53岁。而且非常突然。这真的，它确实让一切都有了一点视角，你知道吗？对我来说是这样，我不知道你失去朋友是什么感觉，但视角是……绝对的，绝对的，有一点，你知道，对我来说是这样，我不知道你失去朋友是什么感觉，但视角是……绝对的，绝对的。这是一个巨大的冲击。是的，医生说的话是令人震惊的，我们不接受的是，人们实际上有预定的日子。我的意思是，有一个
Sometimes we are meant to be of a certain length and yeah, I mean some people are meant to live less long It's it's it's shocking but it's true. And expiration date. Yeah, expiration date. I was doing French, sorry. No. That the peremption. Well, somebody put it well the other day to me. They said, life is a journey, death is a destination.
有时我们注定要活一定的长度，是的，我的意思是有些人注定活得没那么长。这，这，这令人震惊，但这是真的。还有保质期。是的，保质期。我在说法语，抱歉。不。那个预定。嗯，前几天有人说得很好。他们说，生活是一段旅程，死亡是一个目的地。
You know, it's true, because we're all going there. That is true, that is true. And it's like, what do you do with your time? Are we using our time correctly? We're at that age where we are sort of at, past the midway point, we're at that age where you start losing your parents, and mortality really comes into focus.
你知道，这是真的，因为我们都在往那里走。那是真的，那是真的。就像，你用你的时间做什么？我们是否正确地利用了我们的时间？我们到了那个年纪，我们处于，过了中点，我们到了那个年纪，你开始失去父母，死亡真正进入了焦点。
And have you used your time well to this point, and what are you gonna do with your remaining time? A wonderful theme in all of Danny's work. Yes, exactly. But it's a team that is one of the main theme of Arrival and that's one of the thing that I loved about the short story. It was based on the story of your life
到目前为止，你是否很好地利用了你的时间，你打算用剩下的时间做什么？丹尼所有作品中一个美妙的主题。是的，完全正确。但这是一个团队，是《降临》的主要主题之一，这也是我喜欢那个短篇小说的原因之一。它是基于《你一生的故事》
written by Ted Chiang. That is a little masterpiece. And it's about, yeah, living to the present time to make the best out of it and not to be afraid of living because of the fear of death. And that I thought was a nice thing in this movie. In the short story, sorry. First of all, I didn't know it was based on a short story,
由特德·姜所写。那是一个小杰作。它是关于，是的，活在当下，充分利用它，不要因为对死亡的恐惧而害怕生活。我觉得这是这部电影里的一个好东西。抱歉，是在短篇小说里。首先，我不知道它是基于短篇小说，
Sean, you knew that. You have to read the short story. The short story is a masterpiece. It's like 28 pages or something, written by Peng Cheung, a very, very strong sci-fi writer. And it's like a little's a little gem, yeah. I'm gonna look it up today. And I also think just hearing you say that reminds me of,
肖恩，你知道的。你必须读那篇短篇小说。那篇短篇小说是一部杰作。大概28页左右，由特德·姜所写，一位非常非常强大的科幻作家。它就像一个小宝石，是的。我今天要去查一下。我也认为听到你这么说让我想起了，
it's really brought into focus to, it seems almost elementary, like kind of so obvious, but you gotta tell the people you love that you love them. And you've gotta make the most of those. It's not about living the most you want. Like I'm gonna go out and I'm going to parachute today or whatever. It's more that go and spend time and tell the people
它确实让焦点变得清晰，这看起来几乎是基础的，有点太明显了，但你必须告诉你爱的人你爱他们。你必须充分利用这些。这不是关于活得最久。就像我今天要出去跳伞什么的。更多的是去花时间，告诉你爱的人
you love that you love them and be as loving as possible. And I've really been. I think so too. You know, I just saw this thing, Willie, everybody, that the pastor was saying at a commemorate, what is it called? A speech at a college, commencement speech.
你爱他们，并尽可能地去爱。我真的已经……我也这么认为。你知道，我刚才看到了这个，威利，大家，牧师在纪念仪式上说的，那叫什么？在大学的演讲，毕业典礼演讲。
And he said, he goes, I've seen thousands of people die. I've been on the, you know, are hundreds or thousands of whatever he said, standing next to them on their deathbed. And he goes, not one person said in their last breath, bring me all my awards. I want to see my awards one more time. Bring me my certificate from college. I just wanna see my awards one more time. Bring me my certificate from college,
他说，他说，我见过成千上万的人死去。我曾经在，你知道，或者成百上千，无论他说什么，站在他们的临终床边。他说，没有一个人在最后一口气时说，把我所有的奖项都拿来。我想再看一次我的奖项。把我大学的证书拿来，我只想再看一次我的奖项。把我大学的证书拿来，
I just wanna hold it one more time. And he said, what people ask for are the people that they love, like Will was just saying, and that's the only thing they don't say, bring me all the stuff I made. All the achievements I've made. They say, bring me the people I love. And that's it. Well, Danny, I imagine you get access
我只想再拿一次。他说，人们要求的是他们爱的人，就像威尔刚才说的，这是他们唯一不说的事情，把我做的一切东西都拿来。我取得的所有成就。他们说，把我爱的人带给我。就是这样。嗯，丹尼，我想你一定能接触到
to some of the greatest writers, stories, ideas, scripts. Is there, it must be hard to pick and is there something that jumps out at you quickest when a project comes before you? You know, if it's a story about mortality or the human condition or just the human part of something. Is there something that you really like to make movies about sort of a through line that exists in everything?
一些最伟大的作家、故事、想法、剧本。有没有，选择一定很难，当一个项目出现在你面前时，有什么东西能最快地吸引你吗？你知道，如果这是一个关于死亡或人类状况的故事，或者只是关于某事的某种人性部分。有没有什么你真正喜欢拍电影的东西，某种存在于一切事物中的主线？
It's a good question because through the movies I've made, I always have the weird impression sometimes that the movie are choosing me more than I. It's like the project comes and there's something, a connection that is sometimes difficult to explain that is very intimate with the project. But recently I've been more drawn towards books that I, all books that have been with me since a long time, like the Dune books, the books that I have been with me since a long time.
这是一个好问题，因为在我拍过的电影中，我有时会有一种奇怪的印象，即电影选择我多过我选择电影。就像项目来了，有一种联系，有时很难解释，与项目非常亲密。但最近我更倾向于那些我，所有那些一直伴随着我的书，比如《沙丘》系列，那些一直伴随着我的书。
Like the Dune books, the books that I read when I was a teenager. Those books have deep roots in my mind, in my soul, and those books have been with me through the years. And I know that because I have a relationship of decades with these books, I know that because I have a relationship of decades with these books, I know that it means something so deep that it makes sense to spend years trying to adapt them. I would have the same relationship with a book that I am starting to work on
比如《沙丘》系列，我十几岁时读的书。那些书在我的脑海里、灵魂里有很深的根基，那些书多年来一直伴随着我。我知道，因为我和这些书有几十年的关系，我知道，因为我和这些书有几十年的关系，我知道这意味着非常深刻的东西，花几年时间去改编它们是有意义的。我会和一本我开始工作的书有同样的关系，
in adaptation of Arthur C. Clarke Rendez-vous with Rama, which is a space movie that takes place in space. It's a book that I've read when I was very young again. It's a book that stayed with me through the years and when you have roots like that. But to answer to your questions, yeah, existentialism movie about our, why are we here? I love that. our why are we here? Yeah, I was going to say, yeah. Right. I love that. And then is it somewhat daunting to,
改编阿瑟·C·克拉克的《与拉玛相会》，这是一部发生在太空的太空电影。这是一本我小时候又读过的书。这是一本多年来一直伴随着我的书，当你有了这样的根基时。但回答你的问题，是的，关于我们为什么在这里的存在主义电影？我喜欢那个。我们为什么在这里？是的，我正想说，是的。对。我喜欢那个。那么，这是否有点令人生畏，
especially with books that you love, that you've had as a part of you for so long, is it brutal to try to adapt those? Because most books are too long to fit inside of a 120 page script, and so you've got to get rid of a lot of stuff. Now with Dune, fortunately, you were able to break it up into two parts and the second one was the second half
特别是对于你所爱的书，那些作为你的一部分已经很久的书，尝试改编它们是否很残酷？因为大多数书太长了，无法塞进120页的剧本里，所以你必须去掉很多东西。现在有了《沙丘》，幸运的是，你能够把它分成两部分，第二部是书的后半部分。
of the book. Massive fan. Massive fan. As opposed to a sequel. So it's just you broke the book up into two films, which is incredible. The third one potentially. Three, right?
超级粉丝。超级粉丝。而不是续集。所以你只是把书分成了两部电影，这太不可思议了。第三部可能。三部，对吧？
Well the third coming up, right, is a brand new story. It's the second book that will be the adaptation of Dune Messiah, which is the second book. The first movies were about that first book, Dune. It is, the first artist I've approached when I decided to make this adaptation was Hans Zimmer, because I was just out of a movie with him and I absolutely adore working with him on Blade Runner. He's amazing, yeah. 2049 and... For Tracy, that's the composer Hans Zimmer.
嗯，即将到来的第三部，对吧，是一个全新的故事。它是第二本书，将是《沙丘救世主》的改编，这是第二本书。第一部电影是关于第一本书《沙丘》的。它是，当我决定进行这次改编时，我接触的第一位艺术家是汉斯·季默，因为我刚和他拍完一部电影，我非常喜欢在《银翼杀手》中与他合作。他很棒，是的。2049和……对于特雷西，那是作曲家汉斯·季默。
Yeah, yeah, yeah. And he... Why did you choose the composer first? Because I knew that I will need, the score in Dune will be essential, will be absolutely crucial to the success of the movie to bring that kind of sacred quality that I wanted. And also because it's like, it's a matter of context.
是的，是的，是的。他……你为什么先选择作曲家？因为我知道我需要，沙丘里的配乐将是必不可少的，对电影的成功绝对至关重要，以带来我想要的那种神圣的品质。而且因为这就像，这是一个背景问题。
I was working with Hans, he asked me, what will you do next? And we were talking about Dune and I saw his face change because it's his favorite book too. And we start to talk about it and brainstorm about it. And Hans said to me that he had not seen the David Lynch movie because he wanted to stay pure, a virgin. He didn't want to see.
我和汉斯一起工作，他问我，你接下来要做什么？我们正在谈论《沙丘》，我看到他的脸变了，因为这也是他最喜欢的书。我们开始谈论它并集思广益。汉斯告诉我，他没有看过大卫·林奇的电影，因为他想保持纯洁，像处子一样。他不想看。
He said, one day I know I'm going to make the score for a new adaptation. I want to know nothing about what has been done. I want to stay. Why am I talking about this? to know nothing about what has been done. Why am I talking about this? Is it a good idea to get close to a teenager dream? To try to bring to the screen something that is so dear into our hearts. art and it is dangerous. You're meant to fail, you're gonna fail. It's like you have to accept
他说，有一天我知道我会为新的改编制作配乐。我不想知道任何关于已经完成的事情。我想保持……我为什么要谈论这个？知道任何关于已经完成的事情。我为什么要谈论这个？接近一个青少年的梦想是个好主意吗？试图把如此珍视的东西带到银幕上，这很危险。你注定要失败，你会失败的。就像你必须接受
that you're gonna fail, that you will be able to bring a little bit of it, a part of that dream on screen and the rest will be far away from it. And that space between what you achieve, what you were able to bring and the things that are different means that I have space to grow and to get better to make another movie. If I had absolutely succeeded, then I'd be in deep trouble. By that measure, Denis, by that measure, it would seem that if you were to look at it, trying to hit that target of that dream, of a teenage dream, if you will, if you were to do that to the letter,
你会失败，你将能够带出一点点，那个梦想的一部分在银幕上，其余的将离它很远。你所取得的成就与那些不同的事物之间的空间意味着我有成长的空间，变得更好，去拍另一部电影。如果我绝对成功了，那我就有大麻烦了。按照那个标准，丹尼斯，按照那个标准，如果我们要看它，试图击中那个目标，那个青少年梦想，如果你愿意的话，如果你要逐字逐句地做到，
to the number, to be exact, that would be in effect the failure because the success would be everything beyond that, the unknown that you would bring that's new, right? Like that idea. I wonder if, you know, I think about the films that you've made and they have such scope to them. They are these, there's a sort of an epic nature
做到精确，那实际上就是失败，因为成功将是超越那一切的东西，你带来的新的未知，对吧？喜欢那个想法。我想知道，你知道，我想到你拍过的电影，它们有如此大的范围。它们是这些，有一种史诗般的本质
to all of them. I'm such a, like Sean, I'm, and Jason, I'm such a massive fan of your films. And I wonder, they're so ambitious visually, storytelling wise, all of it musically, all those elements, they are so ambitious, visually, storytelling wise, all of it, musically, all those elements, they are very ambitious, they are very big. And what was the, was there a moment when you were young,
在它们所有人身上。我是一个，像肖恩，我，还有杰森，我是你电影的超级粉丝。我想知道，它们在视觉上、叙事上都如此雄心勃勃，所有这些，音乐上，所有这些元素，它们在视觉上、叙事上都如此雄心勃勃，所有这些，音乐上，所有这些元素，它们非常雄心勃勃，它们非常宏大。那么，有没有一个时刻，当你年轻的时候，
when you saw a certain film or a certain type of film, you said, that's, because for me, and Jason, you may be able to answer this too, as a director, are there moments where you go, this is where I want to go? Like, this is the kind of thing that inspires me. But there's one, I remember that one of the first movies that had a big impact on me was, and I saw it on TV,
当你看到某部电影或某种类型的电影，你说，那是，因为对我来说，杰森，你可能也能回答这个问题，作为导演，有没有时刻你会说，这就是我想去的地方？就像，这就是激励我的那种东西。但有一个，我记得对我影响很大的一部电影是，我在电视上看到的，
frankly, was 2001, Space Odyssey. When I saw that film, I was like, woof. That really was like almost a trauma at first. Yeah. Those apes, being afraid of that sculpture in the middle of the desert, like almost a trauma at first. Being afraid of that sculpture in the middle of the desert, it was so frightening and strange and poetic and powerful images. I would say that discovering the work, when I was young,
坦率地说，是《2001太空漫游》。当我看到那部电影时，我就像，呜。那起初真的就像一种创伤。是的。那些猿猴，害怕沙漠中间的那个雕塑，起初就像一种创伤。害怕沙漠中间的那个雕塑，它是如此可怕、奇怪、诗意和强大的图像。我会说，当我年轻的时候，发现……
discovering the work of Steven Spielberg, it was through Close Encounter of the Third Kind. That's a movie that really blew my mind when I was a kid. Also, when I saw Blade Runner the first time, that is another one, the original Blade Runner. That was something that I really... And I'm a Star Wars generation. I had the first movie that I asked my parents to see in the theater the first time. I really, and I'm a Star Wars generation. The first movie that I asked my parents to see
发现史蒂文·斯皮尔伯格的作品，是通过《第三类接触》。那是一部我小时候真正让我大开眼界的电影。还有，当我第一次看到《银翼杀手》时，那是另一部，原版《银翼杀手》。那是我真正……而且我是《星球大战》一代。我第一次要求父母带我去电影院看的第一部电影。我真的，而且我是《星球大战》一代。我第一次要求父母带我去
in the theater, the first time I said I want to see that, usually they were bringing me to the theater, but first time I said I would love to see that, looking at my dad's newspaper, it was Star Wars. And that was something that changed, I remember the oomph, the energy coming out of this movie. It was incredible at the time. I was 10 years old, like probably you.
电影院看的第一部电影，我第一次说我想看那个，通常是他们带我去电影院，但我第一次说我想看那个，看着我爸爸的报纸，那是《星球大战》。那是一件改变了的事情，我记得那种冲击，从这部电影中散发出来的能量。在当时真是不可思议。我10岁，可能和你一样。
I was like the target audience. I was like, the impact of that film was insane. And we will be right back. And now back to the show. Well, you know, something that I love about, I think 2001 might be my favorite film. And the thing that I think really draws me to it time and time again is not only the music,
我就像目标观众。我就像，那部电影的影响力太疯狂了。我们马上回来。现在回到节目。嗯，你知道，我喜欢的一点，我想《2001太空漫游》可能是我的最爱。我认为它一次又一次吸引我的原因不仅是音乐，
but the, and his composition, et cetera. But something that I just realized while you were talking that it does so well that your films do incredibly well is, as Will said, your scope. Your scope, your ability to cinematically capture scope and scale in the obvious large scale, but also in the internal scale as well, the massive scope of a human's internal experience
还有，以及他的构图等等。但我刚才在你说话时意识到的一件事是，它做得非常好，而你的电影做得令人难以置信的好，正如威尔所说，你的范围。你的范围，你从电影上捕捉范围和规模的能力，在明显的宏大尺度上，也在内部尺度上，人类内心体验的巨大范围
in a certain story. Like there are things that are incredibly small and intimate that goes on in 2001, as well as the obvious external large scope of space and these machines and Etc talk a little bit about Your ability to capture that and and did the departments that you're drawn to in filmmaking that that allow for you to travel as as wide on the internal journey of a character as well as the external of
在某个故事里。就像在《2001太空漫游》中发生的事情非常小而亲密，以及太空和这些机器等明显的外部大范围。谈谈你捕捉这一点以及你被电影制作中吸引的部门，这些部门让你能够像在角色的内心旅程中一样广泛地旅行，以及在
These these massive undertakings that you do from a production standpoint. The thing I think that scope and visual effects and things, it's like it's not that difficult. I think that the thing that is a challenge that I'm focusing a lot on set is to try to make sure that the emotional journeys of the actors, of the characters are authentic.
这些你所做的巨大事业中，从制作的角度来看。我认为范围和视觉效果等事情，它并不那么困难。我认为挑战在于，我在片场非常关注的是，尽量确保演员、角色的情感旅程是真实的。
People are talking to me about intimacy, but I think it's more, everybody, all the directors are trying to bring the intimacy, the inner world of the actors, of the characters, sorry, their inner journey on screen, but it's about the inner logic, the authenticity of that journey to make sure that it feels like genuine human reactions.
人们在和我谈论亲密感，但我认为更多的是，每个人，所有的导演都在试图把亲密感，演员、角色的内心世界，抱歉，他们的内心旅程带到银幕上，但这是关于内在逻辑，那个旅程的真实性，以确保它感觉像是真正的人类反应。
And I think that's where the strong emotional impact comes from, when you feel that there's something that feels real, that feels like you can relate to. And it sounds obvious, but specifically in sci-fi, I feel that very often characters don't behave like real humans. It's a personal sensation sometimes that I have. They can be two-dimensional. And it's coming, yeah, maybe it's just like,
我认为这就是强烈情感冲击的来源，当你感觉到有什么东西感觉真实，感觉你可以产生共鸣时。这听起来很明显，但特别是在科幻小说中，我觉得很多时候角色表现得不像真正的人类。这有时是我的一种个人感觉。他们可以是二维的。而且它来自，是的，也许它只是像，
coming from the documentary, I did documentaries when I was young. It's something that I think that I'm really focusing as I'm writing when I write or when I read the screenplay or when I participate in the writing process of a screenplay I try to focus on and with the actors as well I participate in the writing process of a screenplay I try to focus on and with the actors as well. To make sure that that journey feels grounded, has roots in something real.
来自纪录片，我年轻时拍过纪录片。这是我认为我在写作时，当我写作或阅读剧本时，或者当我参与剧本的写作过程时，我真正关注的事情。我尝试关注，和演员们一起，我参与剧本的写作过程时，我尝试关注，和演员们一起。确保那个旅程感觉扎实，在真实的东西中有根基。
So when Amy Adams sees the alien, we believe it a real human reaction. Does it make sense? Yeah, yeah, yeah. Well, Jason, Jason, Jason, you kind of brought it up about that inner and then you were just touching on, I was thinking about specifically Stellan Skarsgård character in the two Dune films, yeah? As this, I forget his character's name. You know, the Baron Arkanen, yeah. Yeah, and he's this, I mean, he's this incredible villain of all villains in a way.
所以当艾米·亚当斯看到外星人时，我们相信这是一个真实的人类反应。这有道理吗？是的，是的，是的。嗯，杰森，杰森，杰森，你提到了那个内在，然后你刚才触及了，我正在思考特别是斯特兰·斯卡斯加德在两部《沙丘》电影中的角色，是的？作为这个，我忘了他的角色名字。你知道，哈克南男爵，是的。是的，他是这个，我的意思是，他是某种意义上所有反派中的终极反派。
He's this sort of despicable person who does sometimes the most awful things. And yet you see in that moment when you see him eyeing the throne and the throne is available. That moment you see he's not just a bad guy like Jabba the Hutt, not to make the comparison or talk down, but you see the envy, you see the desire for that, the thirst, the hunger for it, to reach with his eyes or reaching for it, could it be mine?
他是那种卑鄙的人，有时做最可怕的事情。然而，你在那一刻看到他盯着王座，而王座是空缺的。那一刻你看到他不仅仅是一个像贾巴那样的坏人，不是为了做比较或贬低，但你看到了嫉妒，你看到了对那个的渴望，那种渴求，那种饥饿，用他的眼睛去触碰，或者伸手去拿，它能是我的吗？
In this way that's almost Shakespearean, yeah? But very real and human too. I found that shot of him, when you cut to him, I found that very alarming. Yeah. Well, you're making my day. I thank you so much because you're the first one who's talking about that moment.
以一种几乎是莎士比亚式的方式，是的？但也非常真实和人性化。我发现那个镜头，当你切到他时，我发现那非常令人震惊。是的。嗯，你让我的这一天变得很美好。我非常感谢你，因为你是第一个谈论那个时刻的人。
It's exactly this idea of addiction to power. The man is about to die, but still, the idea that he could get closer to power is like a human addiction. I'm really, thank you very much for pointing that. Yeah, it's evident. But there are components to building a moment like that that you're just uniquely incredible at in your ability to balance all departments
这正是对权力的沉迷的想法。那个人快要死了，但仍然，他能更接近权力的想法就像一种人类的沉迷。我真的，非常感谢你指出这一点。是的，这很明显。但构建这样一个时刻有几个组成部分，你在平衡所有部门的能力方面是独一无二的，
to create that moment. And so for our listeners out there that aren't as familiar with what happens on set and the sequencing of things, talk a little bit about how you approach a moment like that where you know that it needs to have the authenticity of sort of the human condition to counterbalance this crazy odd sort of space world,
以创造那个时刻。所以对于我们那些不太熟悉片场发生的事情和事情顺序的听众，谈谈你是如何处理这样一个时刻的，你知道它需要有人类状况的真实性来平衡这个疯狂奇怪的太空世界，
a nether world that's not really that tangible, but the human emotion is. And so that needs to be real while this other stuff is not that real. And are you thinking I'm fully reliant on the actor to really ground this with no acting and just being raw? Or do you predetermine a certain visual language a certain piece of music from Hans a certain bit of sound design
一个并不是那么有形的虚无世界，但人类情感是真实的。所以这需要是真实的，而其他东西并不是那么真实。你是否在想，我完全依赖演员来真正地用没有表演和只是原始状态来扎实地表现这一点？还是你预先确定了某种视觉语言，来自汉斯的某种音乐，来自你的混音师的某种声音设计，
from your your mixers like you know there's so many different elements that you can do to build a moment just perfectly like that. It's a very good question, thank you. All shots are different from that specific moment where the Baron is like lying on the stairs. It's a character for those who haven't seen the movie, it's a character that is just about to die and see suddenly the throne. The king has left the throne and the throne is up the stairs and he's looking at the throne
你知道有这么多不同的元素可以用来完美地构建这样一个时刻。这是一个很好的问题，谢谢。所有的镜头都与那个男爵躺在楼梯上的特定时刻不同。对于那些没看过电影的人来说，这是一个角色，他快要死了，突然看到了王座。国王离开了王座，王座在楼梯上，他看着王座
and he's looking at the throne and he's crawling towards it. And with a moment like that, I will say it's a very simple image. So it's about Stellan. I explained to Stellan the idea and Stellan Skarsgård, who plays the Baron, will perform and bring that to life. who plays the baron will perform And it's to bring force into an idea. The camera is always very powerful, but it's all the birth of the ideas, acting of course.
他看着王座，他向它爬去。对于这样一个时刻，我会说这是一个非常简单的画面。所以这是关于斯特兰的。我向斯特兰解释了这个想法，饰演男爵的斯特兰·斯卡斯加德会表演并将其带入生活。饰演男爵的会表演，并将想法付诸实践。摄像机总是非常强大，但这一切都是想法的诞生，当然还有表演。
Yeah, that's cool. But let's say perhaps, especially in this. And to answer to about music, it's something for me that it's a power, music is super powerful, but I try to not think about it as I'm shooting because it needs to be on screen first. It's something that...
是的，那很酷。但假设也许，特别是在这个方面。关于音乐，对我来说，这是一种力量，音乐超级强大，但我尽量在拍摄时不考虑它，因为它首先需要出现在银幕上。这是某种……
Well, I had a question about that. Well, let me just finish this one point, though, Shon, sorry. But so, while the music can come and does come much later in the process, the assets you may need on the set to create the visual of it, i.e. a techno crane or whatever it is that you want to shoot that scene in a certain way, you need to have a lot of that stuff predetermined so that you've got your crane there that day
嗯，我有一个关于那个的问题。嗯，让我先完成这一点，肖恩，抱歉。但是，虽然音乐可以在过程的后期出现，而且确实会出现，但你在片场可能需要的资产来创造它的视觉效果，即技术吊臂或任何你想以某种方式拍摄那个场景的东西，你需要预先确定很多东西，这样你那天就有你的吊臂在那里，
and your rigors have set up the lighting in such a way, et cetera, et cetera. So how do you manage the balance between having an actor have the freedom that you wanna give them, but also fit inside sometimes a very technical and pre-thought and heavily prepped visual sequence that you need them to fit inside of? Hit this mark, react this way, turn this direction, you know,
你的索具工以某种方式设置了灯光，等等，等等。所以你是如何管理在给演员你想要给他们的自由，但同时又让他们适应有时非常技术性和预先思考以及经过大量准备的视觉序列之间的平衡的？走到这个标记，这样反应，转向这个方向，你知道，
to fit something that may have other departments all predetermined. It depends. A good example will be the sandworm riding where Timothée Chalamet playing all that 3Ds will attract a sandworm and then when the sandworm arrives nearby him, he will jump on the worm and ride the worm. So it's a sequence that is heavily storyboarded and needs a month of prep. And at this moment, let's say that the choreography that I impose, I'm more of a dictator, I impose a rhythm, a precise choreography that Timothée
为了适应可能已经预先设定好其他部门的某些东西。这取决于具体情况。一个很好的例子是骑沙虫的戏份，提莫西·查拉梅在表演所有那些3D动作时会吸引一只沙虫，然后当沙虫靠近他时，他会跳上虫背并驾驭它。所以这是一个经过精心分镜设计且需要一个月准备的序列。在这一刻，可以说我所强加的编排，我更像是一个独裁者，我强加了一种节奏，一种提莫西必须遵循的精确编排。
has to follow. But inside that choreography, there's tiny moments where Timothée, when I mean close up on him, how he can anticipate the arrival of this beast toward him, the way you can act with his eyes. There's tiny things, the micro-precisions of acting that he can bring. I mean, that I'm open to ideas, but in general, sometimes it's more loose. Some sequences, there's more space for the actor, and those are also, I love when I have time to give space to the actors to bring some ideas.
但在那段编排中，有一些微小的时刻，当我说给他特写时，他如何预判这头野兽向他冲来，他用眼神表演的方式。有一些细微的东西，他能带来的表演上的微观精确度。我的意思是，我对各种想法持开放态度，但总的来说，有时会更宽松一些。有些序列给演员留下了更多的空间，我也很喜欢有时间给演员空间去提出一些想法。
I'm talking about the settings of a scene. give space to theaters to bring some ideas. I'm talking about the settings of a scene. It's very inspiring when people bring good ideas. But complicated sometimes when you have stuff that's predetermined and then you've got an actor that's got different ideas and it's like, well, no, no, no, this isn't one of those scenes where you can freestyle yeah exactly but in the same time it requires tremendous acting skills to be able to perform and to bring life to like to my day facing the worm or any
我是在谈论场景的设置。给演员空间去提出一些想法。我是在谈论场景的设置。当人们提出好的想法时，这非常鼓舞人心。但有时当你有一些预先确定的东西，而演员又有不同的想法时，这就很复杂了，就像是，嗯，不，不，不，这不是那种你可以自由发挥的场景，是的，完全正确，但同时这也需要极高的表演技巧，才能去表演并赋予生命，比如我面对沙虫的那一天，或者任何
Adams facing the aliens or to be in relationship with something that doesn't exist it's like it requires nice imagination and and and it's not easy to the aliens or to be in a relationship with something that doesn't exist. It requires nice imagination and it's not easy for actors to perform in those movies with big toys and all these things. And to answer to your first part of your question about techno cranes or dollies, etc. It's all planned in advance. When I built the scene, it's all drawn, prepared, so we know exactly what kind of technology we'll use on the day, of course. Was there a lot of green screen versus volume stage on Dune 1 and 2?
亚当斯面对外星人，或者与不存在的东西建立关系，这需要很好的想象力，而且并不容易。对于演员来说，在这些拥有大玩具和所有这些东西的电影中表演并不容易。回答你问题的前半部分，关于技术吊臂或移动摄影车等。这一切都是提前计划好的。当我构建场景时，一切都是画好的、准备好的，所以我们当然确切地知道当天会使用什么样的技术。在《沙丘1》和《沙丘2》中，绿幕和虚拟制片舞台的使用比例如何？
Did you use any of the volume stages? Was it all green? We were almost as possible outside in the real environment or with real sets. We built as much as we could and we were in the real environments, in the desert. And those landscapes are for the people who have been in the landscape that are bigger than life, those landscapes are for the people who have been in the landscape that are bigger than life, that bring humility inside you, that the impact on those landscapes is tremendous on the actors and myself and the similar effects.
你们用了虚拟制片舞台吗？全是绿幕吗？我们尽可能多地在室外真实环境或真实布景中拍摄。我们尽可能多地搭建了布景，并且我们身处真实的沙漠环境中。对于那些去过这些景观的人来说，这些景观比生活本身更宏大，它们能带给你内心的谦卑，这些景观对演员、我自己以及类似效果的影响是巨大的。
Yeah, I watched the whole behind the scenes, all of it. All of the doom. We know. Both doom. I couldn't consume enough of it. It was just, I was just blown away with how it's made. We know. How do you do that? The Rake crew. We can erase footsteps in the background, things like that, with CGI,
是的，我看了所有的幕后花絮，全部。所有的《沙丘》。我们知道。两部《沙丘》。我怎么看都看不够。我完全被它的制作方式震撼了。我们知道。你是怎么做到的？耙地的工作人员。我们可以用CGI擦除背景中的脚印之类的东西，
but you cannot have an actor walking in their own footsteps again, because that's a nightmare for VFX. the crew will have the discipline not to make any footsteps. It sounds simple, but it's not. When you have a crew of 800 people in the sand to make sure that everybody follows the same path. It gives the opportunity to see crazy things. Every night when I was going back from the set, when I had sunset, there were 100 people grooming the sand dunes through the footsteps that we had made. So the wind will do its work during the night.
但你不能让演员再次踩在他们自己的脚印上，因为这对视觉特效来说是一场噩梦。工作人员会有纪律不去留下任何脚印。听起来很简单，但事实并非如此。当你有一个800人的团队在沙地上时，要确保每个人都走在同一条路上。这让人有机会看到疯狂的事情。每天晚上我从片场回来时，当太阳落山时，有100人在平整沙丘，抹去我们留下的脚印。这样风在夜里就能完成它的工作。
And it's very poetic. That I felt, oh my God, am I Miguel O'Mahony? Yeah, you're a monster. Because I have people grooming the desert. Sweeping the sand. Believe me, I've had the same thought. Jason made some footsteps in the sand and he yelled at his caddy.
这非常有诗意。我当时觉得，天哪，我是米格尔·奥马哈尼吗？是的，你是个怪物。因为我让人平整沙漠。清扫沙子。相信我，我有过同样的想法。杰森在沙地上留下了一些脚印，他对他球童大喊大叫。
He said, you missed a footprint. When he was playing golf. He's a real monster. But, but didn't he, you know, when I was thinking about, you were talking about the actors and asking them to have imagination and working with them on all these thoughts
他说，你漏掉了一个脚印。当他在打高尔夫球时。他真是个怪物。但是，但是，当我在想，你在谈论演员并要求他们发挥想象力并与他们一起思考所有这些想法时
and these inner life and stuff. And I was thinking about the collaboration that you've had with a bunch of different actors across a bunch of your films. You've used and worked, not used, you've worked with lots of people in different roles. I was trying to think who was, well, certainly our friend Josh Brolin, you've worked with a lot. I think starting in Sicario, which I want to get to. Another great one, yeah. Which is an incredible, I urge anybody,
以及这些内心生活之类的东西。我在想你与你多部电影中许多不同演员的合作。你使用并工作过，不是使用，你与许多不同角色的人合作过。我试着想谁是，嗯，当然是我们的朋友乔什·布洛林，你合作过很多次。我想是从《边境杀手》开始的，我想谈谈那部电影。另一部伟大的作品，是的。那是一部令人难以置信的电影，我敦促任何
if you've never seen Sicario, to please see that. Oh my goodness, so great. It's so phenomenal. Jake Gyllenhaal, you've worked with a couple times, I think, with Prisoners. Emily Blunt. And then our good friend Emily. Jilen Hall, you've worked with a couple times, I think, with Prisoners. You've had a lot of repeat collaborators. It's all about the nature of the project and the parts that remind me,
如果你没看过《边境杀手》，请一定要看。哦天哪，太棒了。太震撼了。杰克·吉伦哈尔，我想你和他合作过几次，在《囚徒》中。艾米莉·布朗特。还有我们的好朋友艾米莉。吉伦哈尔，我想你和他合作过几次，在《囚徒》中。你有很多重复合作的伙伴。这完全取决于项目的性质和那些让我想起的部分，
it's a bit boring, but I wish I could work with all of them again. I think that honestly I adore working in the United States is to have access to all these incredible actors. And casting is very strange. You bring someone on its intuitions about the proximity of an actor and a role, and you take gamble in some ways, but. You, can I go back?
这有点无聊，但我希望我能再次与他们所有人合作。我认为老实说，我喜欢在美国工作，因为可以接触到所有这些令人难以置信的演员。选角非常奇怪。你凭直觉带某人进来，关于演员与角色的契合度，你在某些方面是在赌博，但是。你，我可以回去吗？
Okay, just one really quick question about the music, because I thought that was interesting. You said you were talking to Hans before you started, and do you listen to cues or music about the music, because I thought that was interesting. or do you wait to incorporate it later? I'm going to be very honest. Every time I write or direct listening to music, I'm very sensitive to music. I absolutely love music. I remember once, one of my first films, I was directing a specific scene, as I was alone in my bubble, with my headphones listening to this fantastic piece of music,
好的，关于音乐有一个非常简短的问题，因为我觉得那很有趣。你说你在开始之前和汉斯谈过，你是在听提示音或音乐，关于音乐，因为我觉得那很有趣。还是你等以后再加入？我会非常诚实。每次我写作或导演时都会听音乐，我对音乐非常敏感。我绝对热爱音乐。我记得有一次，在我早期的电影之一中，我正在导演一个特定的场景，当时我独自在我的气泡里，戴着耳机听着这首美妙的音乐，
and I was saying to myself, it's going to be amazing. Whoa, it's going to be something. It's the power of music, you know? Then you look at the scene without the music, like, hmm. It's the same with writing. Sometimes I write something and I get emotional, and I'm like, oh my God, maybe I'm great. And then you read it the next morning.
我对自己说，这将会很棒。哇，这将会很特别。这就是音乐的力量，你知道吗？然后你看着没有音乐的场景，就像，嗯。写作也是一样。有时我写了一些东西，我变得情绪化，我想，天哪，也许我很棒。然后你第二天早上再读它。
It's like, no, it's the music. It sounds stupid, but it's the truth. I cannot work with music. I work with silence. Then I try to, and silence is my friend. I love, my sets are very boring. I'm not a funny director. And silence is my friend. I'm not a funny director.
就像，不，是音乐的作用。这听起来很蠢，但这是事实。我不能在有音乐的情况下工作。我在沉默中工作。然后我尝试，沉默是我的朋友。我喜欢，我的片场非常无聊。我不是一个有趣的导演。沉默是我的朋友。我不是一个有趣的导演。
When I get in the car in the morning, it's total silence. I arrive on set, I need silence. I try to protect that bubble all day long. find my way, when there's music, I'm gone. It's too powerful. And this is why, to answer to your question, it's like, even I have music from the past movies right now, I cannot listen to this music, it's too powerful. Yeah, you introduced me to Max Richter, because I never heard of him.
当我早上上车时，是完全的沉默。我到达片场，我需要沉默。我整天都在努力保护那个气泡。找到我的方式，当有音乐时，我就不在状态了。它太强大了。这就是为什么，回答你的问题，就像，即使我现在有过去电影里的音乐，我也不能听这些音乐，它太强大了。是的，你向我介绍了马克斯·里希特，因为我以前从未听说过他。
And then I was like, what is that piece, it's so powerful. Staying with music though, where for you does the score and the sound design begins? Talk to us about that process for you and when does it happen? First of all, yeah, it has to, I try to think about the sound and the structure of the sound and the structure
然后我就想，那是什么曲子，太震撼了。不过继续谈音乐，对你来说，配乐和声音设计从哪里开始？跟我们谈谈那个过程，以及它是什么时候发生的？首先，是的，它必须，我尽量在剧本中尽可能多地考虑声音和声音设计的结构
of the sound design as much as possible in the screenplay. And I know as I'm writing that I will need music there, I will create a musical sequence more. It's something that is embedded in the DNA of the screenplay. But then when we edit the film, there's like, I'm working with an editor, Joe Walker, who is a master that Joe is coming from, was studied as a composer. He was a composer first, then he did sound at the BBC as a sound editor. So where I'm going is that sound, what I love and one of the reasons I started to work with Joe, we made many movies together, is that for him, sound is as important as the image.
以及声音设计的结构。我知道当我写作时，我会在那里需要音乐，我会创造一个更多的音乐序列。这是嵌入在剧本DNA中的东西。但当我们剪辑电影时，就像，我和剪辑师乔·沃克一起工作，他是一位大师，乔来自，曾作为作曲家学习。他先是作曲家，然后在BBC做声音编辑。所以我想说的是，声音，我所热爱的，以及我开始与乔合作的原因之一，我们一起制作了许多电影，是因为对他来说，声音和画面一样重要。
And it's something that when I was making indie movies, I felt that the sound was coming at the end of the process and with very little time, and I was always kind of disappointed not having the proper time to make a real embedded sound design. And so now I try to bring the sound as early as possible. So it's like as I'm shooting, we have a sound designer that start to create,
这是我在制作独立电影时感觉到的，声音是在过程的最后才出现的，时间非常少，我总是有点失望，没有足够的时间来制作一个真正嵌入的声音设计。所以现在我尽量尽早引入声音。所以就像我在拍摄时，我们有一个声音设计师开始创作，
specifically with sci-fi, to create sounds that will be fed to the editing room very early on. So these sounds are time to live with them and make sure that they will endure the test of time and get used to them These sounds add time to live with them and make sure that they will endure the test of time and get used to them and make sure that they are right through time. It's not just flashes that last minute flashes.
特别是在科幻电影中，创造出很早就被输入到剪辑室的声音。所以这些声音有时间与它们共存，并确保它们能经受住时间的考验，习惯它们，并确保它们随着时间的推移是正确的。它们不仅仅是转瞬即逝的闪光。
And it gives, of course, more time to explore, experiment. And so the sound is something that is, again, as important as the image. And with Joanne Johansson and Anne Zimmer, both composers were flirting close to the sound design sometimes, meaning that the music, sometimes there's like a dance that I install between the designers and the composer that they will flirt and cross sometimes the border It's like a dance that I install between the designers and the composer that they will flirt and cross sometimes the border
当然，这给了更多的时间去探索、实验。所以声音再次强调，和画面一样重要。对于约翰·约翰逊和汉斯·季默，两位作曲家有时会非常接近声音设计，这意味着音乐，有时我在设计师和作曲家之间建立了一种舞蹈，他们会调情，有时会越过边界，就像我在设计师和作曲家之间建立的一种舞蹈，他们会调情，有时会越过边界
and for that it needs communication. But that sound design is embedded prior to you spotting with the composer and figuring out where you're going to put some of the music. It's the sound design first then, yeah? Yeah, but I will say that it depends on the sequence. Sometimes I say to the team, here is hands. Hands is not known to be subtle when you invade the soundtrack. So there are some moments where we say, okay, that's going to be, we go full hands, or here we go. So it's trying to find the right balance between what the scene needs.
为此需要沟通。但那个声音设计是在你与作曲家确定位置并弄清楚你要在哪里放一些音乐之前就嵌入的吗？是先有声音设计，对吧？是的，但我会说这取决于序列。有时我对团队说，这是汉斯。汉斯在入侵原声带时并不以微妙著称。所以有些时刻我们说，好吧，那将会是，我们全力使用汉斯，或者在这里我们去。所以这是在试图找到场景需求之间的正确平衡。
Yeah. It's about the needs. It's the movie that guides me. Yeah, yeah. We'll be right back. And now back to the show. Can we just touch on Sicario for another moment if we could? And just talk about how that came to be, how that came into your purview and what sort
是的。这是关于需求。是电影在引导我。是的，是的。我们马上回来。现在回到节目。我们能再谈谈《边境杀手》吗，如果可以的话？谈谈它是如何产生的，它是如何进入你的视野的，以及是什么
of led you... I don't know, there's something about that film that I find just adore. So visceral. I've been very interested by the border between the United States and Mexico. I thought it was like very meaningful place in the world about our reality, about it was very, and I was looking for, I was reading about it, I was looking for a project that will be, for a story, something that will allow me
引导你……我不知道，那部电影里有些东西我非常喜欢。如此发自肺腑。我对美国和墨西哥之间的边界非常感兴趣。我认为这是一个世界上非常有意义的地方，关于我们的现实，关于它非常，我一直在寻找，我一直在阅读关于它的资料，我一直在寻找一个项目，一个故事，一些能让我
to explore that zone. And came into my hands at one point, I read a lot, but one project came called Sicario, written by Taylor Sheridan. Yeah, the great Taylor Sheridan. The Terradan is well known now for all the work he's done, but at the same time it was one of his first screenplays. And still today it is by far, by far one of the best screenplays I ever read.
去探索那个区域的东西。有一次它到了我手中，我读了很多，但有一个项目叫《边境杀手》，由泰勒·谢里丹编写。是的，伟大的泰勒·谢里丹。泰勒现在因他所做的一切工作而闻名，但当时这是他最早的剧本之一。直到今天，它仍然是我读过的最好的剧本之一，遥遥领先。
The amount of research that Taylor had done to bring that world to life, the best compliment I have about Sicario is when I meet border officers or policemen, the officers that people work at the border who saw Sicario and said, that's the real deal. And honestly, it is because of the work that Taylor had done. He had done his homeworks, and when you were reading the screenplay, you knew you were in front of something that felt authentic.
泰勒为将那个世界带入生活所做的研究量，我关于《边境杀手》得到的最好的赞美是当我遇到边境官员或警察时，那些在边境工作的人看了《边境杀手》并说，那是真实的情况。老实说，这是因为泰勒所做的工作。他做了他的功课，当你读剧本时，你知道你面对的是一些感觉真实的东西。
Very, very strong screenplay. I remember reading it, and I was like, the screenplay was so intense. I finished the screenplay, I was drained of energy. I was like, oh my God, I love it. I'm so sad that I loved this so much. I would have to go in the dark, and I was just out of three very dark movies in a row,
非常，非常强大的剧本。我记得读它的时候，我想，剧本太强烈了。我读完剧本，精力耗尽。我想，天哪，我喜欢它。我很难过我这么喜欢它。我将不得不进入黑暗，而我刚刚连续拍了三部非常黑暗的电影，
and I was like, to go back there. But it was exactly what I was looking for. And it's by far the movie that was the fastest process. I read the screenplay, met the studio, we got along spontaneously, and we did the casting. It went bang! I was behind the camera with Roger Deakins. we got along spontaneously and we did the casting. It went bang! I was behind the camera with Roger Deacon.
我想，要回到那里。但这正是我在寻找的。而且它是迄今为止过程最快的电影。我读了剧本，见了制片厂，我们一拍即合，我们进行了选角。它砰地一声就成了！我和罗杰·狄金斯在摄像机后面。我们一拍即合，我们进行了选角。它砰地一声就成了！我和罗杰·狄金斯在摄像机后面。
It was one of the fastest projects I ever made. It was a very nice shoot because there was a nice balance between the budget and the subject. It was a nice shoot. Yeah, I just want to say, JB, I want to get to your point, which is I just want to touch on the great Taylor shared. And again, you can tell, I never read the script, but you could tell the material was so strong. It really comes through, you know, not just obviously the visual and the way the film is is incredible,
这是我做过的最快的项目之一。这是一次非常好的拍摄，因为预算和主题之间有很好的平衡。这是一次很好的拍摄。是的，我只想说，JB，我想谈谈你的观点，也就是我只想谈谈伟大的泰勒·谢里丹。再说一次，你可以看出，我没读过剧本，但你可以看出材料非常强大。它真的体现出来了，你知道，不仅仅是视觉效果和电影的呈现方式令人难以置信，
but also that the material was really strong. I think it was pretty. I had crazy ideas. I mean, like that border shoot, was really strong. strong sense of cinema. And I'm still grateful that I had a chance to bring that on screen. That shootout you mentioned there at the border is one of the most tense things I've ever seen.
而且材料也非常强大。我认为它很棒。我有一些疯狂的想法。我的意思是，像那场边境枪战，非常强大。强烈的电影感。我仍然很感激我有机会把它搬上银幕。你提到的那场边境枪战是我见过的最紧张的事情之一。
You still probably ever will see it. And there's obviously great planning that goes into something like that because it's just so intricate. But I guess that's my question. How much planning did go into something like that? And just more generally, when you're working, and your visual taste, your aesthetic,
你可能永远还会再看到它。显然，像这样的事情需要很好的计划，因为它太复杂了。但我猜这是我的问题。像那样的事情投入了多少计划？更广泛地说，当你工作时，你的视觉品味，你的审美，
your sense of composition and whatnot is just unmatched. And you're working with your equals in cinematography with people like Roger Dinkins and Greg Fraser. When you sit down and you start to shot design and shot list and previs and all that stuff in prep and decide how you're gonna actually photograph something, what is the relationship with cinematographers like that, that are so accomplished and so in a good way opinionated,
你的构图感等等是无与伦比的。你与罗杰·狄金斯和格雷格·弗雷泽这样的人在摄影方面平起平坐。当你坐下来开始设计镜头、列出镜头清单、预演所有这些准备工作，并决定你将如何实际拍摄某样东西时，与这样成就卓著且以一种好的方式有主见的摄影师的关系是什么样的，
what's the back and forth that goes there? Do you let them know kind of what you're seeing and look for them to kind of plus that or is it the other way around? Do you let them start to design things and then you let them know whether that fits inside your plan? It's a sequence like that battle sequence for instance has to be planned months in advance
来回的交流是怎样的？你让他们知道你看到了什么，并期待他们能增加一些东西，还是反过来？你让他们开始设计东西，然后你让他们知道这是否符合你的计划？像那场战斗序列这样的序列必须提前几个月计划
because it's a puzzle. The different parts have been shot in different places and you have to create a piece of highway with all these cars. It has to be very, very well planned according to the sun positions and so it's storyboarded. And of course working with someone like Roger Dickens will have a strong input. That's what I love. It's like a collaboration. I mean, it's like we will find together the right angle according to the board that I did. But I'm always open if someone has a better idea on set
因为它是一个拼图。不同的部分在不同的地方拍摄，你必须用所有这些车创造一段高速公路。它必须根据太阳的位置进行非常、非常好的计划，所以它是分镜好的。当然，与罗杰·狄金斯这样的人合作会有很强的投入。这就是我所热爱的。这就像一种合作。我的意思是，就像我们将根据我做的分镜一起找到正确的角度。但我总是开放的，如果有人在片场有更好的想法
that will make the shot even stronger. What I think I love working with Roger is that we both are, when we are looking for a shot, looking for the angle, not multiple angle, but one, and we work, we used to work with one camera and that's something that search for the best angle possible is something that we really, really loved. Only one? Wow.
那会让镜头更强大。我想我喜欢与罗杰合作的是，我们俩在寻找镜头、寻找角度时，不是多个角度，而是一个，我们工作，我们过去习惯用一台摄像机工作，那是寻找最佳角度的东西，是我们真正、真正热爱的。只有一个？哇。
I would say it's because I'm monomaniac and it's something that Roger has. We try once to put a second camera on one and it was a disaster. I mean, you feel it, you know it's not right. It's like there's one place to put the camera and the rest is, we are both, on a movie like DOOM sometimes there was additional cameras. It's because of the nature of the piece
我会说这是因为我是单狂，这是罗杰也拥有的东西。我们试过一次在《囚徒》上放第二台摄像机，那是一场灾难。我的意思是，你感觉到了，你知道那不对。就像只有一个地方可以放摄像机，其余的，我们俩，在像《沙丘》这样的电影上，有时会有额外的摄像机。这是因为作品的性质
I didn't have the choice, and Greg Fraser had that flexibility to, but I would say it's- I have four cameras on me right now. Yeah, and we wish it was zero, and we wish it was zero. We wish, is there a possibility to do zero? No, because I want to make sure we get it.
我别无选择，格雷格·弗雷泽有那种灵活性，但我会说这是——我现在有四台摄像机对着我。是的，我们希望是零，我们希望是零。我们希望，有没有可能做零？不，因为我想确保我们拍到了。
Denis, I want to say, I was thinking about your films and your filmography, all the things that you've done, and not only have they been epic as we discussed before and had a tremendous scope, but also you've tackled a lot of, I don't wanna say that they're dark, but there is darkness there.
丹尼斯，我想说，我在想你的电影和你的电影作品，你所做的一切，它们不仅像我们之前讨论的那样史诗般，有着巨大的规模，而且你还处理了很多，我不想说它们是黑暗的，但那里有黑暗。
You challenge people in the sort of the darker realms. Certainly some of your earlier films and your Canadian films that these guys might not know about. Polytechnique and Cindy's. I'm thinking about Polytechnique, which is about the Montreal Massacre, which was a terrible incident in Montreal in 1989.
你在某种程度上挑战人们进入更黑暗的领域。当然，你的一些早期电影和你的加拿大电影，这些人可能不知道。《理工学院》和《焦土之城》。我在想《理工学院》，它是关于蒙特利尔大屠杀的，那是1989年在蒙特利尔发生的一起可怕的事件。
I was there, I was in Montreal at that time. You were? Yeah, yeah. And I was in Montreal in 1989. I was there, I was in Montreal at that time. You were? Yeah, yeah. And I was living there. And I, those films were, as I mentioned before, prisoners and enemy, and then you get into even Sicario. These are heavier subjects that you're tackling. My question is, when's the romcom?
我在那里，我当时在蒙特利尔。你在吗？是的，是的。我在1989年就在蒙特利尔。我在那里，我当时在蒙特利尔。你在吗？是的，是的。我住在那里。我，那些电影，正如我之前提到的，《囚徒》和《宿敌》，然后你进入了《边境杀手》。这些是你正在处理的更沉重的主题。我的问题是，浪漫喜剧什么时候出？
Yeah. Actually, my first feature film was some kind of a rom-com. Was it? Yeah, it's not a good one, but it was. She did lose her life at the end. Actually, he dies. Wow. Hopeless. Actually he dies.
是的。其实，我的第一部剧情片就是某种浪漫喜剧。是吗？是的，它不是一部好电影，但确实是。她在最后失去了生命。其实他死了。哇。绝望。其实他死了。
But it is one of the reasons when I did Sicario, I knew Arrival was coming after and I did Sicario knowing that I would make a movie with more light. And because I was like, it's true that I had made a series of film that was pretty violent and dark. And that is, there's a toll to this. There's like a weight that I needed to go toward. And I think that science fiction also helped me to go toward something like looking in the future or something that's more, there's more light there, I feel right now.
但这是我拍《边境杀手》的原因之一，我知道《降临》会在之后到来，我拍《边境杀手》时知道我会拍一部更有光亮的电影。因为我当时想，确实我拍了一系列相当暴力和黑暗的电影。而且，这需要付出代价。有一种重量是我需要走向的。而且我认为科幻小说也帮助我走向了一些像展望未来或者一些更，那里有更多光亮的东西，我觉得现在。
So it's a... Please don't stop making the dark stuff too, because there is an uplift. I know I was joking. No, but seriously, there's an uplift and an excitement of watching a filmmaker do things at your level, no matter what the genre, what the mood is. JB, would you agree that if somebody says
所以这是一个……请不要停止制作黑暗的东西，因为有一种提升。我知道我在开玩笑。不，但说真的，看着一个电影制作人在你的水平上做事情，无论什么类型，什么情绪，都有一种提升和兴奋感。JB，你同意如果有人说
there's a new Denis Villeneuve film coming out, you're like, where do I line up? Thank you gentlemen, you're very generous with me. No, it's true. Yeah, yeah. Oh, I'm going to shit talk you when this is over. Yeah, yeah, I see that. Well, speaking of the earlier stuff...
有一部新的丹尼斯·维伦纽瓦电影要上映了，你会说，我在哪里排队？谢谢你们，先生们，你们对我非常慷慨。不，这是真的。是的，是的。哦，当这一切结束时，我要说你的坏话。是的，是的，我看到了。好吧，说到早期的东西……
Let's ask Brolin, let's ask Brolin for the real deal. Are there any films from the beginning of your career that you would enjoy perhaps reshooting nowadays, knowing what you know now and do? Not that you have any regrets, but anything that, I should phrase it differently, which film from your past do you think would be most fun to redo now
让我们问问布洛林，让我们问问布洛林真实的情况。在你职业生涯的开始，有没有什么电影是你现在可能喜欢重拍的，知道你现在知道的东西，并且做？并不是说你有什么遗憾，而是任何，我应该换个说法，你觉得你过去的哪部电影现在重拍会最有趣
that you know things now that you didn't know then? Wow, that's a nice question. Do you know that the past movies are like, you're telling me that the past movies are like, the father of those movies. I see movies sometimes as a selfie of yourself. You know when you look at pictures of yourself when you were a teenager? The shame? Yeah, yeah.
因为你知道了那时你不知道的事情？哇，那是个好问题。你知道过去的电影就像，你告诉我过去的电影就像，那些电影的父亲。我有时把电影看作是你自己的自拍。你知道当你看着你十几岁时的照片时吗？羞耻？是的，是的。
shoots? How can you make, say when I make a movie, Ridley makes three movies. And he has a very high pacing. It's just to make sure that your hours, shooting hours are regular. So we do what we call French hours, meaning we shoot 10 hours a day, but without break. No lunch, no breaks. So it means that the hours are always the same.
拍摄？你怎么能做，说当我拍电影时，雷德利拍三部电影。而且他的节奏非常快。这只是为了确保你的工作时间，拍摄时间是规律的。所以我们做我们所谓的法国时间，意味着我们每天拍摄10小时，但没有休息。没有午餐，没有休息。所以这意味着时间总是相同的。
You always start the day at the same time and end the day no overtime, so it's like, it creates a balance in your schedule. So you're not content. You do that on every job? On the past jobs, yes, yes, yes. I didn't do that on Blade Runner and I almost died. Yeah, how are you on night shoots?
你总是准时开始一天，准时结束一天，没有加班，所以它就像，在你的时间表中创造了一种平衡。所以你并不满足。你每份工作都这样做吗？在过去的工作中，是的，是的，是的。我在《银翼杀手》中没有这样做，我差点死了。是的，你夜拍怎么样？
Night shoots will kill people, I mean, literally, unfortunately, at times. Yeah, it's you on night shoots? Night shoots will kill people, I mean, literally, unfortunately. It's about creating a balance in the schedule, trying to find a balance so you will protect the crew from being exhausted. Because for the people who don't know about shooting, it's just that the nature of the structure of the schedule, because of the turnaround of the actors, sometimes you end up starting your day in the middle of the afternoon and finishing late at night. It's not good for creativity. Knocking on an actor's trailer at 3 in the morning, we're ready for you.
夜拍会杀人，我的意思是，字面上，不幸的是，有时。是的，你夜拍怎么样？夜拍会杀人，我的意思是，字面上，不幸的是。这是关于在时间表中创造一种平衡，试图找到一种平衡，这样你就会保护工作人员免于精疲力竭。因为对于那些不知道拍摄的人来说，这只是时间表结构的性质，因为演员的周转，有时你最终在下午中旬开始你的一天，在深夜结束。这对创造力不好。在凌晨3点敲演员的拖车，我们准备好了。
They say, hey guys, it's lunch and it's 12 midnight, and you're like, what do you mean lunch? This is not lunch, I'm sorry. Are you laying on set at 6 p.m. and say hey, good morning, and say cut the crap? Exactly, yeah. Danny, aside from the... Are you a Montreal Canadiens fan, is that what you're going to ask him? Yeah, exactly.
他们说，嘿伙计们，现在是午餐时间，已经是午夜12点了，你就像，你什么意思午餐？这不是午餐，对不起。你下午6点在片场躺着说嘿，早上好，然后说别废话？完全正确，是的。丹尼，除了……你是蒙特利尔加拿大人队的球迷吗，你是要问他这个吗？是的，完全正确。
Well, it was part of it, it's like aside from the good sleep, what's the other thing that you do to really sort of decompress and get away from the incredibly, you know, immersive work directing is? Do you watch something silly on TV? Are you a sports fan? Do you watch hockey?
好吧，这是其中的一部分，就像除了良好的睡眠，你还做什么来真正放松并远离导演这种令人难以置信的、你知道的、沉浸式的工作？你在电视上看一些愚蠢的东西吗？你是体育迷吗？你看曲棍球吗？
No, but as I'm shooting, honestly, when I shoot, I make a 24-hour, seven-days-a-week commitment. There's no way to relax. For me, I'm 100% present to the project. So there's no, specifically, a movie of them. Sci-fi movies, it's every second, not even sci-fi, any movies, there's no way I will recover from a movie is to go back home in Canada, in the forest, go with my family,
不，但当我拍摄时，老实说，当我拍摄时，我做出24小时、每周7天的承诺。没有办法放松。对我来说，我100%专注于项目。所以没有，特别是一部电影。科幻电影，每一秒，甚至不是科幻，任何电影，我从电影中恢复的方法就是回到加拿大，在森林里，和我的家人在一起，
spend time with the kids, with family, and that's where I recharge my batteries. But during a shoot, there's no moment where I can, I know that, and it's that, yeah. And because of that dedication, you will now have made, it will go down in history, Dune as a franchise, just like you loved Star Wars as a franchise as a kid, you created a franchise that will last forever in the minds of these kids.
和孩子们在一起，和家人在一起，那就是我充电的地方。但在拍摄期间，没有我可以，我知道这一点，而且是那样，是的。由于这种奉献精神，你现在已经制作了，它将载入史册，《沙丘》作为一个系列，就像你小时候喜欢《星球大战》作为一个系列一样，你创造了一个将在这些孩子心中永远持续下去的系列。
I would say I didn't do it thinking about the word franchise. For me, it was I was making two movies. Of course. And it was I was making two movies. Of course. Because franchise for me is always like something that is linked with commerce or like there's a plan. Okay, three great movies. Three great movies that are connected. No, but it's not bad.
我会说我做的时候并没有想到“系列”这个词。对我来说，我是在拍两部电影。当然。而且我是在拍两部电影。当然。因为对我来说，系列总是像与商业挂钩的东西，或者像有一个计划。好吧，三部伟大的电影。三部伟大的电影是连接在一起的。不，但这并不坏。
It's just that I was not saying to myself, okay, I'm starting a franchise. It's more about, I'm adapting this book in two movies and we'll see what happens after. But for the fans, we're so happy you're making three of them. But, Sean, not only that, but also, does it ever occur to you, not unlike you looking at your father's newspaper and saying, please take me to this movie,
只是我当时没有对自己说，好吧，我正在开始一个系列。更多的是，我正在把这本书改编成两部电影，我们看看之后会发生什么。但对于粉丝来说，我们很高兴你拍了三部。但是，肖恩，不仅如此，你有没有想过，不像你看着你父亲的报纸说，请带我去看这部电影，
it must be kind of cool knowing that there's somewhere, there is a kid who said to his parents, please take me to Dune, please take me to Dune 2, who 10 years from now says, I wanna study film, who makes a film with people they know and makes a big huge film, and they do it because they saw Dune when they were seven, eight, nine, 10, to be inspiring in that way, I think it must be very cool.
知道在某个地方，有一个孩子对他的父母说，请带我去看《沙丘》，请带我去看《沙丘2》，10年后说，我想学习电影，谁和他们认识的人拍了一部电影，拍了一部巨大的电影，他们这样做是因为他们在七、八、九、十岁时看了《沙丘》，以那种方式激励人心，我想那一定很酷。
I don't know if it had happened or something, but it would be moving to think that people could be inspired. One thing for sure is that I made those movies. We were talking about darkness and violence earlier. The movies were made for PG-13 instead of rated R. It was the first time after, apart from Arrival, all my other movies are for adults. This one I insisted, I agreed with the studio also
我不知道它是否发生过或者什么，但想到人们能受到启发会很感人。有一件事是肯定的，我拍了那些电影。我们之前在谈论黑暗和暴力。这些电影是为PG-13而不是R级制作的。这是第一次，除了《降临》，我所有的其他电影都是给成年人看的。这一次我坚持，我也同意制片厂
to make it PG-13 because I wanted the movie to be accessible to a younger audience that would have the same age as when I read the book. So I thought it was inspiring for me. And adults like me who have the brains of a 13-year-old. Yeah. Yeah. At best. Yeah, but for me, I like the idea
把它做成PG-13，因为我希望这部电影能让年轻观众接触到，他们会和我读这本书时年龄一样大。所以我认为这对我来说很鼓舞人心。还有像我这样有13岁大脑的成年人。是的。是的。充其量。是的，但对我来说，我喜欢这个想法
that those movies are taking themselves seriously, meaning that they are sci-fi that are not, that doesn't apologize to be sci-fi or I love, I remember when I saw The Empire Strikes Back when I was 13 years old, the impact of that movie on me at 12 years old. Oh, God. Yeah, I thought the darkness of it,
那些电影非常认真地对待自己，意味着它们是科幻电影，不是，不为是科幻电影而道歉，或者我喜欢，我记得当我13岁时看《帝国反击战》时，那部电影对我12岁时的影响。哦，天哪。是的，我想它的黑暗，
I felt that there was someone who was talking to me as I was, was trusting me as a kid. And when Darth Vader said, I am your father, I was like, what would that feel like? Inside joke. Oh, just having one. Well, Denis, you seem as kind as you are talented. I just can't thank you enough for talking to us
我觉得有人在和我说话，就像我当时一样，像孩子一样信任我。当达斯·维达说，我是你的父亲时，我当时想，那会是什么感觉？内部笑话。哦，只是有一个。好吧，丹尼斯，你看起来既善良又有才华。我简直无法足够感谢你和我们交谈
at three ding-dongs for an hour. It was a pleasure to chat with you this morning. Yeah. And a pleasure. Thank you very much for the invitation and thank you for your generosity as well. That means the world to me. Well, thank you, sir.
在三个叮当声中谈了一个小时。今天早上和你聊天很愉快。是的。也很愉快。非常感谢你的邀请，也感谢你的慷慨。这对我很重要。好吧，谢谢你，先生。
Thank you, Danny. Congratulations on all your great work. Please keep it coming. Take care. See you later. All right. Good luck, Sean. Thank you, thank you, thank you.
谢谢你，丹尼。祝贺你所有伟大的工作。请继续保持。保重。回头见。好的。祝你好运，肖恩。谢谢，谢谢，谢谢。
Thank you, thank you. Bye. Well, you got blessed by the great Denis Villeneuve, Sean. I think your prospects look good. He just said, basically like, hope you live. Yeah. From the great Denis Villeneuve. He's, yeah, I mean.
谢谢，谢谢。再见。好吧，你得到了伟大的丹尼斯·维伦纽瓦的祝福，肖恩。我觉得你的前景看起来不错。他基本上说的是，希望你活着。是的。来自伟大的丹尼斯·维伦纽瓦。他是，是的，我的意思是。
Hey, if you're out there and you're not familiar, and again, I know that we do like, we compliment our guests a lot because we have people on that we like and we respect and we get shit for it sometimes. You guys just, all you do is compliment. Well, we like to compliment people who are really good at what they do.
嘿，如果你在外面，你不熟悉，再说一次，我知道我们确实喜欢，我们称赞我们的客人很多，因为我们有我们喜欢和尊重的人，我们有时会因此受到指责。你们只是，你们所做的只是称赞。好吧，我们喜欢称赞那些在他们所做的事情上真正出色的人。
And if you're not familiar who Denis Villeneuve is, and you're not familiar with his films for some reason, I really, this is true, I urge you to go and watch some of his films, all of his films, his Canadian films that he made and his current, he's just an incredible, I mean JB is a director, right? Just stunning, yeah, he's not, there aren't many in his league.
如果你不熟悉丹尼斯·维伦纽瓦是谁，而且你因为某种原因不熟悉他的电影，我真的，这是真的，我敦促你去看看他的一些电影，他所有的电影，他制作的加拿大电影和他现在的电影，他只是一个令人难以置信的，我的意思是JB是一个导演，对吧？太棒了，是的，他不是，在他的联盟里没有多少人。
I think it's probably about, it ain't deeper than 10 and it's probably closer to five. No, and again, he made Brolin look good, you know what I mean? Oh, it's very hard to do. I mean, think about that shows what a filmmaker he is. Yeah, I think how many cameras that takes. Off the, you know?
我想这可能大约是10，可能更接近5。不，再说一次，他让布洛林看起来很好，你知道我的意思吗？哦，这很难做到。我的意思是，想想那需要多少摄像机。离开，你知道吗？
But he's really cool. He's... So cool. Yeah, and you can tell he's in charge, which I love. Canadians are cool, right? Yeah, the accent I think he needs to work on a little bit. He's from Des Moines. But he's... No, he's not from Des Moines. But I think-
但他真的很酷。他是……太酷了。是的，你可以看出他在负责，我喜欢这一点。加拿大人很酷，对吧？是的，口音我觉得他需要稍微努力一点。他是得梅因人。但他……不，他不是得梅因人。但我认为——
No, he's not from Des Moines. No, he's like, wait, what? No, dummy. God. He's from, I think he's from Montreal, yeah? Yeah. Quebec. Well, Montreal is in Quebec, but it's a province.
不，他不是得梅因人。不，他就像，等等，什么？不，笨蛋。天哪。他是，我想他是蒙特利尔人，对吧？是的。魁北克。好吧，蒙特利尔在魁北克，但它是一个省。
He's not related to Jacques Villeneuve or Gilles Villeneuve. Sure, yeah. But- I don't know who those people are. Those are Formula One drivers. They were. Oh, excellent. Wonderful. They were. You know what? Here he comes. What's up, Sean?
他与雅克·维伦纽瓦或吉尔·维伦纽瓦没有关系。当然，是的。但是——我不知道那些人是谁。那是F1赛车手。他们是。哦，太棒了。太好了。他们是。你知道吗？他来了。怎么了，肖恩？
I love that he brought Close Encounters up. Oh yeah, why's that? Well, because when, I remember that one moment when you all saw the movie, yeah. This is gonna be so lazy. Oh, when the spaceship takes off. Honestly yeah This is gonna be so lazy. This is honestly this is gonna be so Freaking when the little kid is standing there waving Waving to the aliens as they're leaving. He actually says out loud
我喜欢他提到《第三类接触》。哦，是的，为什么？好吧，因为当，我记得你们所有人都看那部电影的那一刻，是的。这会很懒。哦，当宇宙飞船起飞时。老实说，是的，这会很懒。这老实说这会很疯狂，当那个小孩子站在那里挥手，向外星人挥手告别时。他实际上大声说
What does he say? Bye! Bye! Do do do! Do do do! Bye! Bye! Bye! Bye!
他说什么？再见！再见！嘟嘟嘟！嘟嘟嘟！再见！再见！再见！再见！
Bye! Bye! Bye! Bye! Bye! Bye! Bye! Bye!
再见！再见！再见！再见！再见！再见！再见！再见！
Bye! Bye! Bye! Bye! Bye! SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armjarf, and Bennett Barbeco. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再见！再见！再见！再见！SmartLess是由迈克尔·格兰特·特里、罗布·阿姆贾夫和贝内特·巴贝科100%有机和手工制作的。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。